in the interest of efficiency we'll be
responding rapid fire style to uh Tick
Tock videos attacking me just over the
past two weeks or so so we're going to
go through a number of rebuttals here in
the interest of time I had to choose
only four from the options my producers
sent to me and uh there were a lot more
though and I say this will be rapid fire
but take that with a great assault I'm
not Ben Shapiro so rapid fire is
relative anyway let's go through these I
wouldn't really call this an apology and
make no mistake Dylan Mulvaney is our
enemy he is an open visible active and
passionate Advocate or the abuse of
children the war on fundamental truth
the destruction of human society as we
know it no Dylan Mulvaney does not
advocate for child abuse and gender
affirm and Care isn't child abuse anyway
as it's been found that not providing
trans Healthcare to youth is actually
closer to a form of child abuse Brands
kids who are rejected from their family
were nearly 60 more likely to commit
suicide 73 more likely to end up in
prison and 68 more likely to suffer from
substance abuse one study found that 73
of trans youth experience psychological
abuse and 39 physical abuse so we can
clearly prove that trans people are not
committing child abuse but for the other
two claims I don't know what to do about
that they're so over the top and
dramatic war on Truth the downfall of
society how can you prove or disprove
that this is where I think Matt Walsh's
resentment has a little bit more to do
with Envy I mean I resent Matt Walsh
because I think he's a fascist but I do
also envy him I envy his status his
platform the fact that people might take
him more seriously than they'll take me
but what if anything does Matt Walsh
Envy about queer people does he Envy
Dylan because she grew to such
popularity so fast is he envious of the
fact that she got invited to things like
fashion shows different events that
she's met the president now we've
already dealt extensively with the claim
that gender transition decreases suicide
rates to the charge that I am envious uh
because Dylan Mulvaney gets to go to
fashion shows I don't know what to say
except in attending a fashion show would
be my actual hell I mean almost as bad
as going to a WNBA game and I'm already
going to be forced to do that so A man
can only take so much as for meeting the
president yes I admit that I would be
very eager for a chance to sit across
from the president with the cameras
rolling but for very different reasons
so overall no I'm not envious of Dylan
Mulvaney I mean in order to elicit Envy
he would need to have something that I
want or embody some sort of trait that I
find admirable instead he has none of
the things I want out of life and
embodies everything that I want to be
the opposite of so what we've learned
here as you even admitted to your credit
I suppose is that you are driven by Envy
and so you assume that everyone else is
too and this is what we call projection
now the next video is from the same guy
so uh let's continue Matt Walsh is a
fascist who is promoting violence
against trans people his language is
inflammatory and factually incorrect the
idea that being trans is the result of
some kind of social contagion has been
disproven so many times the theory of
Rapid onset gender dysphoria comes from
a survey of 256 parents of trans
children and not from the trans children
themselves the article has been removed
and criticized for bad methodology after
being peer-reviewed it was found that
rapid onset genders for it isn't even a
formal medical diagnosis it was found
that between 2017 and 2019 the rates of
teenagers identifying as trans didn't
even increase well where to begin you
say that the survey about rapid onset
gender dysphoria was invalid because
they interviewed parents rather than the
children themselves well yes if a child
is sucked into a social contagion he's
not going to report that he's been
sucked into a social contagion are you
actually trying to prove that children
aren't being indoctrinated by arguing
that the indoctrinated children say they
haven't been indoctrinated is that what
you're going with yes I mean if you go
to your local Scientology Center and you
ask anyone there whether they've been
brainwashed they're all going to say no
I guess that proves that there's no
brainwashing happening there either they
didn't say they were brainwashed so I
guess they weren't now if you uh if you
don't like the term rapid onset gender
dysphoria you can call it whatever you
want if you prefer something less
clinical sounding then just call it uh
wow look at all of these kids calling
themselves trans all of a sudden
syndrome the point is that according to
data compiled by the Williams Institute
for example nearly one in five people
who identify as trans are between the
ages of 13 and 17. only half a percent
of all adults in this country identify
as trans while the number for kids
between the ages of 13 and 17 is 1.4
that's nearly three times higher and the
numbers are even more striking when you
break them down by generation there was
a Gallup poll that found that there are
twice as many trans identifiers in gen Z
as there are among Millennials and there
are many more among Millennials than
among Baby Boomers for Baby Boomers it's
uh 0.2 percent identify as trans for Gen
Z it's it's nearly two percent point two
percent versus two percent that is a 10
X increase you think this happened by
accident or perhaps you would say that
there have always been this many trans
people in the world but they weren't
free to live their truth or whatever
well the trouble with that theory is
that there's absolutely not even one
single shred of evidence to support the
dramatic claim that there have always
been Millions upon millions of closeted
trans people through history
so here's how this breaks down all of
the available data all of it tells us
that there are many many many many many
many
more trans identifying people in the
youngest generation than in any other
generation in human history you can
either believe what the data tells you
what all of it tells you all of it or
you can invent a story entirely
unsupported completely built on your
imagination about millions and millions
and millions of theoretical trans people
in older Generations who don't show up
in the data
this is what you're reduced to because
you don't want to accept what your eyes
tell you and tell all of us that trans
identification has skyrocketed in recent
years you're left then theorizing about
invisible trans people and other
Generations even though you have no
evidence that they even exist I believe
in working hard for what you have who do
you trust to handle any and all of your
financial obligations if you can
according to a recent poll 62 of
Americans who think about their own
death a lot of the time still do not
have a will that's kind of like being
afraid of drowning but refusing to wear
a life jacket creating a will is one of
the most important things you can do to
ensure that your belongings and your
loved ones are taken care of after you
pass away my partners at Epic will can
help you get set up with a will today
for just 119 dollars in as little as
five minutes epic will can help you
create your last will and testament your
living will even Healthcare power of
attorney go to epicworld.com Walsh to
get my discount code and an extra 10 off
on your complete will package with epic
will it's easy to use template all you
have to do is fill in the blanks they
couldn't make it easier for you go to
epicworld.com slash Walsh to save 10 on
Epic Will's complete will package that's
epicwell.com Walsh today I had an
unfortunate experience today when I
logged onto Facebook and I saw this post
by Matt Walsh I'll be honest with you I
thought it was satire I thought Matt
Walsh was either making a joke or that
he had been hacked but upon further
investigation
this was serious so let's read it
together
all a man wants is to come home from a
long day at work to a great full wife
and children who are glad to see him and
dinner cooking on the stove this is
literally all it takes to make a man
happy we are simple give us this and you
will have given us nearly everything we
need the only truth in this entire post
is where he says we are simple you're
right you guys are simple-minded little
it gets better when he moves to the
comment section because people obviously
give him a bunch of
if your husband is unhappy consider
whether you have ever given him this one
thing he wants there's a good chance the
answer is no
oh the outrage obviously every situation
is different maybe the situation where
both spouses have to work especially in
this economy maybe the man Works
different shifts basically yeah I know
I'm a idiot I don't know if I've
told y'all this story about when I was
being abused in my marriage and I I'm
not to like toot my own horn I was a
pretty good wife like I was the wife who
stayed fairly fit after two C-sections I
kept the house clean I did the laundry I
made the dinner the kids were happy and
well behaved and disciplined and I tried
my hardest because this is how I was
raised okay this is I was raised by a
stay-at-home mom I was raised with kind
of the mindset of like this is your job
is to like make him know that like he's
appreciated and that his house is taken
care of and yada yada on top of all that
I did all the fun little things in the
bedroom he wanted me to do I would send
him dirty pictures at work and try to
keep the spice alive I would buy new
lingerie everything that you can think
of I was like I'm gonna be a good wife
like I am going to make this this work
and I got more and more desperate to try
to be a better wife the worse it got
because I was taught like this Matt
Walsh post that if it failed if the
marriage failed if we weren't happy if
he wasn't happy it was on me it was
because I wasn't grateful enough it was
because dinner wasn't ready soon enough
it was because I wasn't fun enough I
wasn't spicy enough and he still abused
me he still cheated I'm sorry you had
that experience in your marriage I am
never should have happened but you're
making a mistake that many people make
these days of assuming that a general
principle is wrong because of your own
personal experience so it's like if I
said that you should lock your doors at
night and use an alarm system to prevent
break-ins and you responded that my
advice is bad because you did that and
still had to break it okay but does that
mean that you shouldn't lock your doors
and use an alarm system if a certain
strategy isn't totally foolproof and
perfect does it automatically make it
bad what I'm recommending is that women
should be grateful and loving towards
their husbands that's it that's all I'm
saying now it's true that you could be
grateful and loving to your husband and
still end up in a terrible marriage
because he's a terrible person that can
happen terrible people exist in the
world and there are people who end up
married to terrible people it does
happen and it happens on both ends
because they're terrible women and
terrible men
but does that mean that wives shouldn't
be grateful and loving I mean are you
recommending in gratitude and resentment
is that a better strategy is that more
likely to produce positive marital
results you could be faithful to your
spouse and still find that he is
Unfaithful but does that mean that we
should tell people to be unfaithful from
the start on the assumption that the
others will be too of course not
but maybe your point is that we
shouldn't put it all in the wife we
should tell the men to be grateful and
loving too well here's the good news I
never suggest otherwise in fact I
frequently encourage men to love their
wives and be faithful and good to them I
say that all the time I just didn't
happen to make that point in that
particular statement that you read there
are many points that I didn't make
because I was only making the point that
I did make I can't say everything every
time I say anything and that limitation
does not give you the right to invent a
whole series of opinions and statements
I never expressed which is what you just
did
all right uh last one let's watch it you
cannot be something and also the
negation of that thing at the same time
Matt Walsh is just going to be upset
with people using micro labels see he he
wants to have it both ways where he
hates the oversaturation of language of
microlabels yet when something is not
100 consistent and precise enough he
gets mad at that too you can't have it
both ways either we have to use umbrella
terms which are not going to be exactly
precise yet as long as we understand
that if somebody says bisexual and
asexual they're probably referring to
romantic attraction to both genders or
perhaps a little sexual attraction to
both genders if this is the position
that Matt Walsh is taking it is going to
be logically inconsistent for him to
later pick issue with micro labeling
five minutes later part sniffing mumbo
jumbo and now he's taking issue with
micro labeling despite earlier
complaining that macro labeling is not
specific enough well thank you for
reminding me about my fart sniffing
mumbo jumbo I'm quite proud of that
now my issue is not with the act of
labeling there is some amount of
labeling that's necessary and normal
human beings label things so that they
can communicate coherently with each
other about those things but coherence
is the point here when the labels create
incoherence then they defeat the purpose
of the entire exercise if the label
doesn't clarify but rather creates more
confusion then it's not even a label
it's more of an anti-label it's an
attempt to make it harder for people to
understand what something is not easier
my issue with the labeling that you
people do is that you label obsessively
and constantly but your labels don't
make sense and they don't cohere they
contradict themselves and you can't
Define any of them that's the problem
case in point you mentioned someone who
identifies as both bisexual and asexual
that doesn't make sense I'm not being
pedantic I'm not engaging in a game of
gotcha here it just doesn't make sense
it is a logical contradiction it is the
definition of something that doesn't
make sense calling yourself a bisexual
asexual is exactly like calling yourself
a meat eating vegan now you say that
perhaps asexuals experience a little
sexual attraction to both sexes and that
somehow justifies calling an asexual
that sort a bisexual asexual but that's
like saying that a meat eating vegan is
a vegan who eats only a little bit of
meat well by definition if you eat a
little bit of meat then you eat meat
which means you aren't a vegan you may
be a less enthusiastic meat eater or a
reluctant meat eater or an occasional
meat eater or maybe there's some other
adjective you can affix there but a
vegan is someone who doesn't eat meat
period
you eat meat you aren't a vegan an
asexual experiences no sexual attraction
If you experience sexual attraction
you're not asexual see this is the other
problem with your compulsive and
incoherent labeling you don't allow for
variations within the labels you pretend
that you do you're all about variation
you embrace all kinds of variety you
claim but you don't because the moment
you notice a variation within a category
you create a whole new category for that
variation
so rather than just allowing for the
fact that sexual people heterosexual
homosexual people who experience sexual
attraction rather than allowing for the
fact that there are varying sexual
appetites and there are uh you know
people that are that have greater
appetites than others rather than just
allowing for that you carve out anyone
with a lower appetite and you put them
in the asexual box you've removed them
from this box and put them in this one
instead and you do this kind of thing
everywhere in every context the most
obvious example of course is how you've
eliminated masculine women from
existence tomboys we used to call them
you've erased that variation by labeling
them trans men see this is the worst
part about the way that you label it's
not just that it's incoherent it's also
that it's so damned limiting and
furthermore
you're canceled all of these people in
fact are today unfortunately I must say
cancel
[Music]